everyone's favorite journalist Taylor
Len is furious because over on threads
she's being censored that's right for a
while now we knew that Mark Zuckerberg's
threads app which is supposed to rival
Twitter SLX was censorious I mean it's
run by Facebook Facebook is one of the
worst Tik tok's a bit worse but this
matters because we're now getting
reports that Walmart is joining The
Advertiser boycott and well we were
initially thinking of launching the
story with a comment from dick Durban
senator of Senator out of Illinois
Democrat saying that we should be
enlisting illegal immigrants
non-citizens into the army because of
the shortfall I thought well look we
can't have these conversations if the
platforms that allow Free Speech are
destroyed but this is while bad I think
there is some good in this many of these
people on the left these woke reporters
cannot deny now that Mark Zuckerberg is
worse for you than Twitter would have
been and if you want to be able to
criticize even Elon Musk you're going to
have to use x